[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
first of all gentlemen thank you thank
you very much for being here Andy let me
let's take care of your a neck injury
now when was the win was the match April
5th right and it's now almost August do
you still need that neck brace on there
yes yeah
are you in a lot of pain well I'm not in
as nearly as much pain as I was and it's
it's healing but it's still enough to
her the brace huh
one of those kind of nagging lingering
injuries that I don't know what you call
it but I just have to wear the brace now
it was three people two boys and one
girl
and they was carrying the biggest cannon
in the world to Spain so they carried it
over the mountains and under the valleys
and one day they get to the highest
mountain in Spain they are on the top so
the the first boy point this cannon to
this castle and he turned to the second
buyer and say all right hand me the
cannon ball so this does indeed this
second why he say I thought you Adam
[Applause]
they like give you the punch
they both turn to the girl and she say
don't look at me you know because they
may forget opening the cannonballs they
could not shoot they have the cancer but
they have no cannon ball you understand
when I see Jerry here I've never seen
the man in person before to me you'd
have to be nuts to want to get into the
ring with this guy he appears to be
maybe twice your weight and and he's
better-looking what was
I'm just just teasing there you know but
what wide what was your motivation for
wanting to fight him well I had had so
many matches with women and I always won
and I started really believing that I
was a good wrestler I don't know I'd
beaten women but the bigger than him I
really thought that I could beat him
it's nice to see ya
tell me about gum tell me about taxi
was you like a tissue game would you
like a tissue
[Music]
[Applause]
so tell me about that
[Applause]
beautiful
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll be salut
here Oh
now in this next sketch for friends to
married couples are out to dinner on a
Saturday night now each one has secretly
brought along a joint thinking that for
one reason or other no one else in the
group smokes dope so each person leaves
the table what he or she does is sneak
into the restroom to get a little high
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what I I can't just say I can't
play I don't know I can't play stone
this is Graham and she's great stupid
[Laughter]
yeah
[Applause]
come on hey this is my it's going fun
come on right it's all in fun
this is all it's all in fun come on
where are we now
[Music]
everyone around you I don't understand
I don't understand one thing no
seriously why everyone is going boo on
like the joke and when I told some of
the jokes and then when I don't want you
to laugh you're laughing like right now
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen thank you
I think I
it's not working so
[Music]
so I think um thank you very much and
I'm sorry and there's other accents so I
really shouldn't have done this I had
other stuff I was gonna do for you but I
don't think I should so I just want to
say thank you and you know I'm I'm just
trying to do don't have you don't have
to really I'm just trying to do my best
to have some fun and if you don't like
it that's it
okay thank you very much good night
[Applause]
[Music]
you know I'm not trying to show any
talent I'm trying all I'm trying to do
is have some fun this is when I get
together with friends we go home and I
have some fun and I just wanted to leave
you're my friends and we're having a
good time I have no business here and I
want to thank you all for sure
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much
[Applause]